did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
biomimicry is learning from and then
emulating nature's best ideas chances
are the camera that you're using has a
lens inspired by moth eyes one of the
things about lenses is that you don't
want them to reflect a lot of light you
want them to drink in light and to hold
the light a moth has the same issue as a
night flying creature it needs to drink
in as much moonlight as it can but it
doesn't want to have that light shine
back because if it does it creates a
shine which a predator can see so it
wants its eye to be absolutely black and
the way it does this is it has these
tiny pillars on the outside of the eye
and light comes in bounces around but it
can't bounce back out these have been
mimicked on films that are being put on
cameras to make them anti-reflective
they're being put on solar cells so that
a solar cell drinks in the maximum
amount of light without reflecting a
whole lot all based on a small common
but actually pretty cool creature come
on to learn more about biomimicry
subscribe to the wired Channel
you